très très touchant un avion tout à
l'heure on va se comparer deux casques
et pour le faire ce qui a nuit quand
même cette première salle c'est premier
casque
le deuxième c'est celui-là c'est le
surface est l'fun de microsoft
donc on met tous bords up dans la valise
le surface iphone ce quelque part aussi
vite qu'on va le prendre avec et on va
regarder
lequel est le meilleur
ils se parlent
[Musique]
c'est par ici
alors aujourd'hui on se teste le nouveau
casque de microsoft qui dans cette jolie
boîte là c'est le surface et fun l'idée
c'est d'essayer de voir s'il intéressant
et on va le comparer par rapport aux
cascades sonic le w h melixon 3 voir
lequel est le mieux si et ça d'autant
plus que coûte quasiment le même prix
alors c'est une toute première fois que
microsoft ou sera casque à réduction de
bruit première fois franchement il perd
encourageantes
déjà quand vous regardez un peu en terme
d'esthétique
il est plutôt pas mal alors après c'est
une question goût on aime on n'aime pas
je trouve bien le confort franchement
est cool et il est bien enveloppants il
vient bien prendre votre oreille en plus
côté plutôt cool ça se met sur l'avant
quand vous le prenez vous mettez comme
ça
les écouteurs sur l'avant c'est plutôt
pas mal le confort est bien maintenant
lorsque vous l'avez un petit moment sur
la tête déjà vous n'allez pas de points
de pression là il englobe bien vos
oreilles
mais lorsque vous changez que vous
passez ensuite sur le mail xm3 vous avez
l'impression de mettre des pantoufles
il est bien où je préfère le casque de
sonny gallant il ya un peu plus d
expertise de la part de sony sens parce
que là ça fait un peu plus longtemps que
sony fait des castes comme ça donc on va
y aller doucement d'autant plus que je
trouve que microsoft pas franchement
dire et aussi sa commission alors saint
cast va être un tout petit peu plus
lourd que celui de sony il fait 2 154 g
écrit 290 g bon 16 ou franchement à
trois fois rien maintenant la différence
ils pointent le plus important on va se
faire au niveau du son et il ya deux
trois points de différences qui font que
ce cas ce que la et franchement hyper
encouragement mais on n'y est pas encore
il manque encore deux trois trucs au
niveau du son vous avez une une belle
maîtrise haut niveau
grave les aigus sont assez précis par
contre dans medium ça manque un peu de
précision ce que j'ai regretté c'est
qu'il parle d'applications android et
ios pour venir régler son équaliseur ça
c'est franchement le point négatif à la
différence de sony vous avez une appli
vous pouvez venir complètement
paramétrique pouvez paramétrer la
spatialisation pouvait venir choisir vos
équaliseur alors déjà de base leçon sony
est très bien après on peut vraiment
bien réglé selon ses préférences et
c'est un peu ce qui manque alors vous
pouvez le faire via une application que
vous allez installer sur votre
ordinateur sur votre pc
mais c'est dommage parce que si vous
n'avez pas de pc avec vous si vous
n'avez pas du tout pc ou alors carrément
si vous avez un mac c'est un peu
embêtant d'autant plus qu' on utilise
ces petites bêtes avec ses smartphones
je trouve que ça c'est vraiment un
regret il faudrait vraiment que
microsoft sorte une application surface
et fun ce pour ios et pour android sans
être vraiment un sens c'est ça mon avis
c'est vraiment là dessus que ça
l'empêché parce que les médiums sont un
peu brouillon et j'aimerais vraiment
pouvoir les corriger dans un équaliseur
bande par m'enfermant paramétrage perso
voilà c'est un petit peu là dessus que
ça pêche
[Musique]
à côté de ça et il ya du sang et a
franchement du son ce qui est cool au
niveau de ce casque c'est la façon à
pouvoir l'utiliser joue entre vous le
mettez comme ça sur votre tronche jusque
là je vous apprends absolument rien et
là vous avez une molette
là ça tourne vous allez régler le sont
plus ou moins forts donc c'est vachement
intuitif
ça c'est vraiment vraiment bien et le
côté vous avez réglé la la réduction de
bruit plus vous allez le monte plus vous
allez avoir une réduction bruit qui va
être importante et plus vous allez décès
est loin vous aider à voir avec son
briquet importante et vous allez après
amplifier le son extérieur notamment si
vous allez courir si vous avez besoin de
savoir ce qui se passe autour de vous
bon c'est une fonction qu'on les utilise
pas mais en tout cas je trouve que c'est
pas mal alors puisque je vous parle de
réduction de bruit elle est pas mal très
franchement elle est pas mal mais on
n'est pas au niveau de ce casque là le
casque w/h 1000x m3 qui a franchement
une excellente traduction de bruit
néanmoins microsoft a vraiment fait du
bon boulot pour un premier casque à
réduction de bruit franchement il n'a
rien à envier au vent ne vous allez voir
que positionnement tarifaire va mon avis
causé quelques difficultés à microsoft
pendant ce casque après vous avez un
petit bouton ici pour l'allumer pour
l'éteindre vous le branchez ici en usb
c'est vous pouvez mettre un jack 3.5 de
ce point de vue là il est franchement
cool et après ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que vous avez des
pavés tactiles tout ça ça parait tactile
exactement la même chose de l'autre côté
ce qui fait que vous appuyez une fois
cause la lecture deux fois morceau
suivant trois fois morceau précédent
c'est franchement très très intuitif et
ça hyper cool et c'est ce qui pourrait
manquer la dessus alors vous avez
effectivement un pavé tactile mais je
trouve beaucoup moins intuitif et
beaucoup moins pratique que celui de
microsoft donc ça microsoft franchement
c'est hyper cool en plus de ça vous avez
la puissance si vous poussez le volume à
fond franchement c'est vraiment beaucoup
de sang en castes alors l'idée il faut
faire quand même hyper gaffe ne pas se
rendre source relativement important
mais c'est vrai qu'en termes de
puissance il répond bien le son est pas
mal mais les médiums un peu à me voir
après l'autonomie pas mal vous le
charger en deux heures en usb c'est 15
heures d'autonomie 50 heures d'ailleurs
si vous le branchez en plus diack
autre point qui est intéressant lorsque
vous avez votre casque pour écouter de
la musique
si vous l'enlevez comme ça hop il coupe
la musique vous leur mettez y vont mais
la musique c'est du point de détail mais
c'est pas mal
vous avez bien évidemment vous en
montrer des micros pour déjà la
réduction gris ambiante mais en plus ça
vous pouvez passer des appels
téléphoniques beau sensiblement la même
chose point qui est pas mal et qui m'ont
vraiment que c'est un casque est destiné
aux personnes qui utilisent microsoft et
notamment cortana c'est qu'effectivement
vous avez cortana avec mais pas de
google assistant pas d'amazon avec ça
c'est pareil quand même relativement
logique microsoft à son nid à derrière
c'est ça qui est bien et qui peut être
un peu limitative c'est à dire que c'est
un casque qui va vraiment être utilisés
par les personnes qui sont fans de
microsoft qui vont utiliser la gamme
surface qui vont utiliser cortana et là
il ya un vrai sens si par contre vous
utilisez google assistant si vous êtes
sur un os
à mon avis vous irez plus là dessus non
pas que vous alliez syrie mais vous
allez google assistant est à mon avis un
casque le questionner qui va se destiner
à plus de personnes tandis que celui là
sera un peu plus je regarde ni chez
pascal beaucoup de monde qui utilisent
les produits microsoft on est qu'il sera
vraiment destiné aux fans des produits
microsoft
autrefois qui pourrait manquer c'est
justement du fait qu'on n'est pas
l'application on peut pas venir le
paramétrer au niveau de la pression
atmosphérique alors situe le point de
détail mais si vous prenez l'avion
le casque sony beaucoup plus optimisée
lorsque vous allez être en altitude il
va pas venir vous calculez votre
pression atmosphérique vous n'allez pas
être un bar mais à 0,8 là dessus vous
avez une seule pression elle bouge pas
c'est bon c'est du point de détail ne
fait plus mais quand vous arrivez à des
budgets aux alentours d'un peu moins de
400 euros pour un casque vous voyez 50
quand même c'est un casque qui se vend à
379 euros
ce qu'on voit très clairement c'est que
c'est un très bon premier coup d'essayer
de la part de microsoft pense que ça va
être difficile pour rivaliser avec des
casques comme buzz lors au diamant
réduction de bruit le casque de sony qui
il n'ya plus loin notamment avec une
application qui va être dédiée qui nous
permettra de venir paramétrer votre
casque de nouveau les co leaders on
la pression atmosphérique il est quand
même plus confortable même si je suis là
et pas mal
franchement il est pas mal mais c'est
vrai qu'il est quand même un peu plus
confortable et en termes de qualité
audio le casque saunier meilleure ni
moins je trouve que microsoft pour voir
que c'est une première fois à vraiment
bien bossé sur ce casque le design est
cool après on aime on n'aime pas mais je
trouve intéressant je trouve très
intuitif avec le côté des petite molette
le pavé tactile est franchement hyper
simple à utiliser il synchronise très
rapidement voir il ya quelques points
encore amélioré si microsoft veut
vraiment cartonné sur ce segment des
casques à réduction de bruit
en tout cas c'est vraiment hyper
encourageant pour une première fois je
sais pas ce que vous en pensez vous
dites moi ce que vous en pensez en
commentaire vous êtes plus sur lequel
sony wmx m3 ou alors le surface et phone
de microsoft ou de marquer tout ça en
bas et on en reparle voilà nous
embrassons prenez soin de votre show